[Music]
and this is rogue theory it's a show
where we bring a bunch of fun people
together and we get their ideas and
opinions on topics that are in pop
culture esight Geist
Eric's giggling because I'm milking a
tiny cow and for no reason
today's episode we do I'm being milked
and then we also have improviser and
comedic saxophone what does that mean I
play saxophone in comedy setting oh no I
mean vizor saxophone in comedy settings
cuz what makes something funnier but
just a loud saxophone yeah which sex
alto nice me too okay and then also
that's true Terry Erickson channel the
terror Erickson yeah it's just under my
name no just tear Erickson the tear
Erickson is my twitter handle confusing
they're switching it now I mean you
really guys reminder you can listen to
the show i botched it you listen to the
show row three podcast feed earlier than
the video version if you do it on iTunes
or anywhere you get your podcast this
episode by the way this is our post
comic-con episode yeah even the last
episode we kind of pretended that we
knew we had shot it before so we didn't
know so we're gonna talk about all the
big stuff from comic-con the biggest
stuff of course it's mainly the Top Gun
news after we are going to talk about
Top Gun though
but guys we're new rockstars hi nice to
meet you
we will be talking about Marvel a lot
right now specifically starting with
phase for now the titling of this video
may have been clicked baby I'm not sure
if it was depending on what it is
I can see chances are yes if its new Rex
okay great and it may have said
something about the death of the MCU
phase four is this crazy like tectonic
shift across the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it certainly is gonna look
nothing like what it looked like before
and we were we were just talking about
this before the show we realized it's
actually going to break everything we
know about superhero movies so we have
some topics about the things that we are
no longer gonna see in the MCU and how
it's shifting something new and then
we'll kind of see like is it is the MCU
as we knew it
dead why not so first off let's talk
about the superhero genre because I'm
that's something I'm arguing is over
even within Marvel they're not going to
make superhero movies anymore you know
what I mean which isn't that interesting
like they said each director who came
out kind of talked about what sub-genre
their movie would be scott derrickson
said Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness best title of all time will be a
horror movie will be the MCS first scary
film and that Black Widow seems to be
kind of like a Jason Bourne style spy
thriller this but this is a trend that
we have seen in the MCU for a while now
you know like it's interesting how
unlike other superhero movies they don't
tend to call each other Iron Man or
Captain America unless it's like in this
tongue-in-cheek way they refer to each
other as Tony as Sam
Steve Clint yeah nicknames Point Break
Lebowski you know it's all kind of done
in this grounded kind of chill funny way
but in a way they've almost kind of
turned away from the traditional hero in
a cape trope and all of their everything
they have is like armor or a utility
suit as opposed to just something you
wear for theatrics or if it is something
you wear for theatrics there's a purpose
behind that as we saw unlike Spider Man
far from home
Clinton Beck's wardrobe was theatrical
and that of an actor but there was an
agenda behind that so it seems like
phase four is doubling down on that
trend and now we are we're moving away
from this whole idea of superhero origin
stories with the concept of oh my dad
was not good to me and so I became a
billionaire yes orphan over
yeah usually goes to somewhere near
Tibet story now writing orphan like find
some some way it's what is it dog bites
man isn't isn't news but Man Bites Dog -
would be yeah they need to find these
like these shifts and I think that
that's definitely what they're doing
what you guys thank well I was just
gonna say it sounds like it's something
that's gonna be more grounded and
something that could actually a person
could actually get to you being an
Avenger from the path that they took if
they're talking about as I heard that
the widow movies gonna kind of reference
their Budapest adventure that happened
so it's like Oh as opposed to like when
I got bit by a spider and I kind of got
to figure it out I got bit by a black
widow and I'm dead yeah it's like this
is how I became Who I am realistically
in this universe I think that's kind of
cool and also like the the jumping in
for a second to the the horror of Doctor
Strange to me that's what I'm saying I'm
like that's a shanwa right superhero is
to me no longer a genre it's a
jumping-off point
that's a motif or something or it's a
character right like a clown horror or I
mean like it's just a word that you can
put up on a hoarder but it is is the
overall genre done why felt like Captain
Marvel they really followed her
storyline well like in what you're
saying she was pretty grounded but she's
still a superhero to me it's just maybe
not as like old-school right it's
probably a superhero movie in a very
traditional yeah but it's like we all
care about the story about like the
redemption of like the kid to the
teenager to the woman I think that's
what people attach to more is this story
where they came from so that you can
associate to those characters rather
than just like it's Captain Marvel and
like you want all her gear and like to
go out and be her on Halloween but
really it's like the story that you
attached you from like a kid or now or
when you see the movie of like oh I like
that person like you know you like
either Doctor Strange or you like Black
Widow more like you attached to those
characters I think because of their
backgrounds yeah and I peep it I
honestly think that Marvel's been doing
this and that's why we had in
that's why we attached to them because
even Ironman story was like hey I'm this
punk kid that gets basically kidnapped
and I have to become a better human and
this is how yeah and then builds his
supersuit around a persona of being
something better I mean it didn't start
out that way but that's what it grew
into and I and I think now they're
really saying hey we're gonna lean into
following them as people and not as them
as what is their power you know what I
think it is I think we have found maybe
the studio's have found a sort of
exhaustion in realizing that a superhero
movie isn't really a genre maybe it's
just like this Joseph Campbell's story
structure this hero's journey it's not a
story structure than a genre because
what are the tropes of a superhero
movies some kind of origin moment or
someone has some kind of inherent
personality flaw or weakness that
somehow they try that either gets
accentuated or complemented by some new
power or technology or magic that they
uncover I mean all these things are
technical consistently which it is
exactly the hero's journey just with the
word super yeah exactly
and so you could argue I think I've
argued before that Harry Potter is in a
way a superhero movie the matrix is in a
way of superhero movies Star Wars is in
a way a superhero movie because if you
just detach like the specific details of
the Star Wars names and places and just
puts any kind of like if you put Adam
warlock in there people be like oh now
it's a superhero movie so right yeah
maybe it was based on the comics if you
look so considering for fans that aren't
familiar with the hero's journey every
movie we watch is is basically the
hero's journey or some variation on that
so then if you think of that and then
you think well superhero is really just
superhuman is what we're talking about
that's why you pick the matrix neo is a
superhuman right you can go beyond
literally though the word super going
beyond what a human is so if you just
take that superhuman concept and then
know that every story is a hero's
journey concept then yeah it's almost
like anything that it has powers like
cybela me then they can be called a
superhero thing which is why I love this
idea of phase four to me looks nothing
like what we've come to learn from the
tradition
hero's journey instead yeah I actually
kind of disagree a little bit but some
of what you guys are saying I think it's
like we're gonna go into dr. Strange's
like alternate realities and it's gonna
be like this completely impossible for
us to conceive reality it's almost a
little like Inception how we talked
about that a lot from the first Doctor
Strange movie
we're like these are not concepts that
that was the concept of grounding them
is almost impossible they did a lot of
great work with the original original
Iron Man films to ground the whole
universe but they called him a punk kid
by the way he's a billionaire arms
dealer but he was also a punk kid that's
right yeah and that it is those those
things were it's like you can't be a
billionaire and then that's just it you
have to be like like do you know
billionaires are weird they are Jeff
Bezos young must yeah cuz people are
super weird so grounding it
appropriately did give them the ability
now to go I I won't argue completely
ungrounded and that's how you end up
with a horror movie in the MCU as
they're saying yeah I hope that they
continue to go more toward fewer origin
stories like the Eternals I do not want
to see an opening 30-minute prologue
explaining to me Salma Hayek was born
like how old Blade Runner opens with
like a couple paragraphs just explaining
what replicants are and then we jump so
with Eternals with shang-chi i don't
need i would love it if they did the
same thing that they did with spider-man
homecoming even though spider-man's most
famous superhero everyone knows who he
is and what his origin story is I don't
think we need that much Captain Marvel I
think had a really good structure where
we just jumped in with her with this
Star Force elite commando team and the
movie becomes about her discovering what
her origin was but that wasn't
structurally what we had to sit through
for the first 40 minutes of movie quick
question Schanke that's the new is that
gonna be a part of Eternals or is that
no it's gonna be supposed to be more of
like a like a kung-fu style for it just
wanted to make sure that I was for the
right
martial arts - movie that has that still
has this weird ten rings MCU connected
like the ten rings have shown up in
several MCU movies they were in the
first Ironman
they were weirdly an ant-man there were
one of the like armed Steelers who were
meeting to try to get this technology
they yeah they showed up there were
connected to the Mandarin and Iron Man 3
like the false Mandarin they were there
the whole time and some people said that
they're an even bigger threat than like
Hydra might have been or Thanos might
have been but I don't know about that
but they're not gonna go like it's not
as bad as Hydra yeah but it's it's it
seems like that's gonna be its own
separate story that is also weirdly
interconnected to the rest of the
universe so I wanna I want to bring up
we can go up of shang-chi here the idea
that I you know it is gonna be this kung
fu film that it's just gonna happen to
be a Marvel movie we are kind of all
like putting aside the fact that Iron
Fist happened yeah right and you know
there's a few little redeeming qualities
in that show but overall not a great
show but I do want to talk about this
next part of the death of the MCU I my
voice would not sustain being gravely
for even one second but and that's the
death of the the previous distinction
between the films and TV shows because
Iron Fist Marvel stamp on it real big on
Netflix even agents of shield which
technically was part of the MCU yeah
still kind of started to veer off on its
own thing even though they were reacting
but now on the phase four timeline
big-screen BAM right there is one
division right and Falcon and Winter
Soldier they clearly are elevating these
things to be on the same par as the
movies so I want to talk about is this
good are we talking about doing TV shows
and just like pretending they're really
important are they instead actually not
gonna be anything like a TV show before
be more like a six hour movie what do we
think how are they if they are breaking
down this barrier what does that mean
for the content I mean I would love if
there was a different structure and
variety for each show depending on what
we want like
if one division truly is going to be a
preamble or a pre-show setting up dr.
strange in the multiverse of madness
then yeah maybe like a for episode
miniseries but something like yeah a
falcon Winter Soldier I could see that
being of SC realized I could see a
hundred episodes of that Marvel what if
like a million episodes of that so some
of these could be more open-ended things
some of them maybe we only do one season
and we're done with it right one
division especially if so are you guys
familiar with the House of M story
called it's it's essentially a scarlet
witch's thing right later big thing
where she finally fulfills her potential
and I would argue that in the MCU she
kind of hasn't right and so in the
comics she you know without giving away
too much in case they on say do a lot of
it
she has an overreaction to you know
something sad she she loses children I
dr. strange is actually for some reason
the doctor that delivers the children
but so so which could be why she's tied
into his movie it could be but long
story short she gets rid of the mutants
no more mutants right and it wipes out
mutant powers for almost everyone so a
lot of people are thinking this could be
the creation of the mutants instead and
some sort of reverse kind of thing which
we talked about other versions of how
the mounds might come into the MCU but I
mean is it this is are they giving this
the huge the biggest thing they've ever
had this merger with Fox the big moment
bringing the mutants over are they gonna
give that to a TV show I mean look at
Game of Thrones like any like if just
take a page out of HBO's book because I
canceled so many subscriptions so that I
can pay for HBO just to watch Game of
Thrones and then I end up keeping it for
all of their other shows and so I'm like
yeah if you want to have a miniseries of
like six episodes and they're like so
great I think you there that's what
they're going to do
I think it opens it up because there's
always like we're gonna go do this you
guys go do this and then there's like
something else happening and then they
can lend that to these other little they
can have these little mini series or
this is what this TV show is kind of how
this starts off and you can kind of
follow everyone's story somewhere yeah
that's really cool there's like an
ability for them to link it all together
like I do think that it would it would
be super cool if blade was with dr.
strange in the horror like aspect of it
that would be so fun right like there's
so many ways and now that they can you
know just like connect all of these
characters depending upon what episodes
they film they have access to all of
them and I also think it makes it easier
for viewers if you're like hey I'm a
huge vision fan but you know forget
Black Widow then you can just kind of
follow that by itself
yeah and Link that it for sure and I
think what it tells us is that now
Disney with Disney Plus is banking on
the fact that increasingly more people
are watching stuff through streaming
platforms and if you look at the numbers
the few numbers that Netflix ever ever
gives us there that Adam Sandler movie
murder-mystery it like thirty million
people or something like that watched it
like you watched it like ten I watched
you and stranger things made huge
numbers people if they can have
immediate access to this and already
paying for this subscription you know
for better or worse when it comes to
film exhibition more and more people are
watching stuff on their Smart TVs on
their phones on their you know whatever
their watches I don't have one
I don't like time it reminds me of my
impending death but yeah I think Disney
Plus is kind of looking into the future
and seen well maybe we're gonna have
fewer and fewer people who all go to
movie theaters and now we can find a way
to get directly into people's homes and
control how much content they can watch
and have them pay for specific tiers and
what they were just gonna treadmill to
earn credits do 50 million merits really
yeah but I think we're like we're
getting to that era for better or worse
but what this does mean is it takes some
of the pressure off of each film if you
think the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
been a 10 year long or TV series
in each one's kind of like an episode of
that now they're kind of going more in
that vector where they can kind of
control week by week how things connect
and we're talking about yeah blade
connecting to either one division or dr.
strange in the multi person madness
there's even an idea like some people
are saying maybe dr. strange should go
into the land of the dead and and the
death realm and then commune with fallen
heroes and maybe that's where he finds
vision soul and drags them back into
into life like there's all kinds of
weird ways these things to connect and
when you are producing things on a
smaller scale you can make those
decisions kind of on a moment-to-moment
basis as opposed to three times a year I
think it's interesting that you you said
it really quickly but we're like man
like they could be doing these they
could be so ballsy and do these amazing
things and TV shows and films and it's
almost like you know they've had this
with this plan in this amazing creative
way and it's kind of like or you're
launching a streaming service and you
are like hey you know how to make people
sign up for a streaming service part of
the essential story is there and just
FOMO alone right just like yeah unless
you pay us monthly like they're
literally like it's like the the
enforcer something on your on your block
who's kind of like hey we've been
protecting you real nice for a while but
the price is going up and so why we've
just enjoyed we've been really good
viewers or if it's like because we can
yeah we can make you pay now monthly for
your Marvel content I mean hell yeah
what was bringing Elizabeth - it wasn't
I mean did you guys see the Doctor
Strange panel they bring back out
Elizabeth Olsen and Kevin Feige he's
like yeah and one division is gonna be
very important in this movie were very
excited about it's like is it or do you
really just want us to watch the least
exciting series do you remember the
thing they said was gonna be fifties
esque oh I don't remember see now that
was a long time ago but they said that
it would it would be the vibe would be
the 1950s which goes with if you read
that kind of recent comic division it's
it's vision has a whole family and it's
really creepy and dark and weird but
it's set in like Americana as 1950s
reality I wonder if he's gonna do that
with Scarlet Witch somehow if they do
bring vision back they're not a hundred
percent on this but they were I feel
like they were also talking about
back Captain America's girlfriend Peggy
Carter is a part of this 19 which would
work than if the whatever is actually
gonna be in the first episode of the
what if but so so I want to kind of
pivot for a second to just one more
thing about we kind of touched on it but
I want to narrow it and pop it off is
the idea that somebody say gross yeah I
forgot where I was going no it's the
idea that if there's one more thing
that's dying we kind of touched on it
but let's just go specific the death of
the concept of a super hero and I'm
gonna go through what you guys have
brought up a couple times now and that's
blade right like obviously we had Wesley
Snipes is blade and then they arrested
him for tax evasion and he wasn't
allowed to return to the MCU but there
wasn't one but is is this part is this
wide are they just crumbling these
things because outside of the Avengers
the heroes do get kind of weird and you
know they're anti heroes in their part
vampire and stuff i or what do you guys
just think about this idea of you know
shang-chi and all these characters like
is the concept of a superhero is that
dead just the way it not the sean roe
but i puff person you know you're
bringing up kind of a both DC and marvel
and the comics went through this phase
in the early nineties we saw the death
of Superman and that's kind of the
conversation we were having like are
people tired of just seeing Boy Scouts
go off on fight others some other kind
of metaphor for some country where it
were with and then in the mid 2000 the
Civil War storyline we saw the death of
Captain America and some people saw that
as like does that mean the death of
American values and American goodness
because we were in the middle of like
this war overseas
and I think yeah we might be going
through a similar thing in the cinematic
universe like we're we're done with
these kind of stories we want to see
people become more anti-heroes seen like
movies like Joker where it's someone who
is a definite villain in the comics now
become the protagonists were following
we've definitely know their people do it
but Marvel doing yeah now Marvel's gonna
follow ensue yes interesting there's no
there's no death to superheroes it's
like people are still gonna be dressing
as every MCU character of Chiron in
Halloween for the next like 20 years I
just don't think I think yeah sure they
maybe change it a little bit maybe open
them up seem more human but then I just
think that the audience is looking for
that anyway I know that you want her
here but you kind of also want like I
want to be able to relate to you a
little bit more like I didn't fall into
weird sand and get powers just a
billionaire marbles kind of following
the like the human zeitgeist I feel like
I'm using that in a weird way guys
however it's like a pause support you
whereas when Ironman started to come out
that was like right around and obviously
I'm not a hundred percent on the dates
and stuff but like that was right around
9/11 like we were going through a time
we were going through a time where it
was like famous specifically the first
post 9/11 like yeah it's like doing the
Iraq war or the Afghanistan warrior and
I think now we're going into a phase as
humanity where it's like we are human we
need to see each other as human and what
makes us real we're all talking about
self care learning about who we are
really digging in and you know taking
care of ourselves and putting ourselves
out there and I think that that's also
changing within in entertainment itself
and I think that's why we're starting to
get these movies like how did the Joker
be well he's this is mental illness
we're talking about you know and it made
somebody become it a villain that not
only was hurting himself but now is
hurting other people and how do we stop
this interesting get to be a cook really
quick I think really I I think that
there is a moment happening in the
zeitgeist of what it means to be a
person in personhood right apparently
it's a corporation as a person but a
side of aside from that it's like the
this spectrum of what a person is
I mean I'm yes I am straight of talking
like what
not your sister door what not her or
honestly the immigration issues right of
like are you treating these people like
people rather than contraband or
something huh I and just all these
definitions of these are people earlier
we were saying that superhuman well the
human part is the important part maybe
they're breaking down well then what is
human let's make it reflective of
everything hence shang-chi hence salma
hayek being at the leader of the
Eternals right like it sounds like oh
well they're just squeezing in diversity
you know we're gonna talk about Thoreau
later obviously a lot of people are
thinking that they're too but also it
could just be like or they're being
reflective of cultures you know what
every person whether or not you agree
with their politics or what they define
themselves as they should be able to
find themselves in the MCU somewhere
yeah because they exist in the real just
reflecting the world as it is exactly I
know it we're using the term death
because people understand what death is
but like you can also look at death as
transformation you know or transition
it's either through reincarnation or
through literally scientifically when
you die your body's nutrients go into
the soil when you look at us flowers and
I will never die we're watch I will the
if we look at it that way all this is a
natural cycle it's like what we learned
in throw a rag rock right like it's the
end of something but it's also the
transformation into the best version of
Thor that we've seen in the MCU so we
kind of that's a natural point and this
is we're getting back to the hero's
journey right like death is a critical
part of the life cycle for every
character and it's that kind of
resurrection on the other side of the
transformation that defines who they are
so if you can look at phase four it's
kind of the transformation the
resurrection we saw one life cycle and
Ragnarok has occurred and now there's
going to be using the nutrients and the
elements and the materials of what we've
seen we're going to synthesize something
even better on the other side of it yeah
I feel like like in the Joker trailer
when you see him with his mom and she's
you know she's sick and she's gonna die
that sort of transforms him into this
character where you do find him going up
to the Wayne house and he gets pushed
away and falls over and that's his like
that's the moment where you're like oh
you chose this path because of all these
things that led up to this moment where
now
you are the Joker and that moment in the
trailer is scary but also really
redemptive like when you see it and the
music and he's like on the stairs it's
so cool
and I just think following just that
storyline of me watching that trailer
I'm like that's real that's like real
life like people have sick parents and
they have to like go through really hard
things and then they don't turn into the
Joker but they could turn into an angry
they could or like an angry you know
person who might end up in a psych ward
like yeah is showing you if we haven't
previously seen this and some would
argue wait we might not need to but what
is interesting to us right now is it's
taking the extreme we were talking
earlier about grounding these characters
the extreme character of the Joker and
giving you an A to B to C to get there
and then making you ask how many cracks
away are you from becoming the Joker
which apparently is not that many you
just gotta get shoved in front of a rich
guys house yep and then you're all
you're on your lap guys we gotta take a
quick break to thank the sponsors that
bring this show to us rogue theory is
paid for by the things that I talk about
next new rock stars rogue three is
brought to you by some very nice
sponsors did you spend a little too much
going to comic-con this year or maybe on
that sick Jon Snow cosplay that had to
have fake fur but it had to be super
realistic and that costs a lot of money
- is this just me I'm talking about
probably but maybe you like me have
really high credit card bills right now
and that high interest rate is really
bumming you out bad so what do you do
you get a credit card consolidation loan
from lights cream with rates as low as
five point nine five percent APR with
Auto pay the application is super simple
there are no fees and you can get money
in your account as soon as the day you
apply I mean it's not snapping fingers
to bring back half the life in the
universe fast but it's pretty fast so
just for our listeners applying now to
get a special interest rate discount the
only way to get this discount is to go
to light shrimp comm slash rock stars Li
gh t stre a m.com slash rock stars of
course this is all subject to credit
approval and that rate includes 0.5%
auto pay discount terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice
visit light stream comm slash rock stars
for more information all right back to
it thanks so much to those sponsors guys
Thor love and thunder we gotta talk
about it now you designed the logo
correct I did wooden to paint good
gradients for paint on do you start yes
we've been talking about the these
redefining of superheroes and maybe what
if the concept of the superhero is
changing or dying in some way what's
replacing it taking one of the core
Avengers and now replacing the mantle at
least of Thor with Natalie Portman's
character Jane Foster I that is
something that's happen in the comics
but what does it mean that that's
happening in the MCU I and just how do
we even think they're gonna do it I
don't know that I'm a fan okay first of
all I have not read the comic so I don't
I don't I didn't know that this is
something that also happened inside of
the comics okay that's pretty recent -
yeah okay like Black Panther style where
they just oh we're reviving the movie
now we're gonna have a season's long
time he was a longtime artist for it but
it was in the past five or six years
that they told this side story involving
the original sin and the Mighty Thor
Thor dropped his hammer because of
something Nick Fury whispered in his ear
messages with his head dropped it and
then an unknown female character picks
it up becomes lady Thor kicks a bunch of
ass and we find out it's Jane Foster who
has breast cancer and every time she she
uses the hammer to power up it resets
her chemo so it's kind of this it's
really human stories it's fascinating
she's dying to say but people yes and
she it's it's a pretty interesting run a
bit a bit divisive not everyone loved it
but it's a very like fresh take I think
on the character again grounded yeah so
so what aren't you feeling they're just
like it just take acknowledge the
perspective okay so you don't know from
the comics neither do most people who
are familiar with the MCU so then what
is turning you off about it
I guess my problem with it is that her
character has been separated from she
was in the first movie she was like a
little bit maybe in the reference they
think in the second just reference in
the third she's just been referenced
ever since
it feels very far removed to then bring
her back end
last week we argued that Valkyrie could
have done it right that Jeff character
feels very fresh and if there was gonna
be a female Thor there's somebody who
had seemed worthy certainly with Tessa
Thompson's character but yeah it does
honestly it's the Natalie Portman drama
right didn't she like hey Dean yeah yeah
she just as an actress she's one my
favorite actresses Justin was done with
him so yeah we're best friends
yeah she's but yeah she kind of seemed
like just done with them see you and
it's like I might feel a bit different
if they brought in the different actress
to play Jane Foster and I don't prom
with Jane Foster being Thor I guess I
don't really have with Natalie Portman
to be an authority I kind of feel
similar in that the way it was presented
it almost felt like an apology for the
past Thor movies where no one like Thor
has never been more popular than he was
after Ragnarok and during the Infinity
Ward in gay movies why are we now like
apologizing it's fine if like we want to
make a movie where both he and Jane
Foster can both be Thor and it's like
this awesome rom-com I'm down for that
but the way it seemed like you know
Taika Waititi got down on one knee he
handed this thing to this Hollywood
a-lister and now she's the queen of the
MCU the way you you just made it seem
like she held the the hammer is not
actually actually how it is it very much
he's like grimacing yeah
he doesn't want to do it it seems like
it does this storyline a disservice
potentially by giving it so much of
spotlight so much attention it's like
have you guys taken Natalie Portman's
masterclass class yeah she walks around
the room and she's like you need this is
how you experience it she's like okay
the camera really feel it you know and
so I'm like yeah all right she's like
look for props that you can break
masters like don't do this please
yeah she'll be able to get a lot for the
next master class out of this for sure
if she's got cancer and she's gotta be
yeah Lanie Thor saved the world I have
the highest hopes for this movie I think
Taika Waititi did a great job and I
think he understands what's good about
this what I think is a really good Jason
Aaron comic series and I hope this is
what I hope for the movie that they are
able to elevate Natalie Portman in a way
that doesn't throw down or knock down
Chris Hemsworth or just we've already
seen that we saw him get knocked down in
in in game and infinity war and in
Ragnarok so like let's have that be a
true like team movie again and see their
relationship unfold as they both like
trade-off the powers of Thor maybe she
does have cancer they want to bring that
in
maybe he decides out of an act of love
and thunder hand off mil near to her so
it's like a choice rather than like he's
d powered because you know this just
gonna piss off the haters if they do it
that way baby you may not know this
Chris Hemsworth is not gonna be in it
she's gonna be I'm thinking we're
kidding ourselves if we even think that
he's not gonna be still the star of the
movie like just be more titled if it is
a mantle being passed I think that's not
quite I don't want to say Abbey story
but I think maybe it's a way to elevate
that character so that she can be maybe
it is a buddy team-up kind of thing but
Valkyrie is gonna be a big part of it
too let's address the thing that people
are throwing out there is it a love
triangle is that what the love is about
where Valkyrie said that if she's the
king of Asgard Cheney circuits our queen
who's just been elevated to worthy Jane
Foster who is still crushing on Jane
Foster Thor is oh so it's like Valkyrie
and both Thor crushing on Jane Patel
yeah yeah Valkyries gonna win she's got
tushy
yeah I wouldn't I would love that a lot
of people have been shipping Captain
Marvel and Valkyrie that they've had
some social media posts some love back
and forth that'd be great I would love
Captain Marvel to show up in this story
just because there was that you know fun
chemistry between her and Thor and
endgame I want to go sweet sweet babies
[Laughter]
for it yeah yeah do you guys think it'll
be that it'll be a love triangle
who it should if it's not they're
failing big time or look trying words
just like Jane and Valkyrie are doing
their thing and Thor's left out of it
and he's still there he's just like okay
tonal burning inside like their kind of
thing remember me guys like know what
else other than the love triangle also
Erik's pitch of out of an act of love
what else could the love and be
referring to probably like that she has
to have a love for the people to be able
to give a lot of her life away like
she's killing herself every time she
like turns under because you'll say that
that Thor doesn't do it for the saving
the people part right he's an action
junkie in the best way
Jane sacrifices herself every time if we
can get more stories explaining to
people what love is and how it's not
this simplistic overly romanticized
thing but it's a complicated compromise
based sacrificial thing where you you
know it's a four-letter word that has no
meaning let's like let's teach people
how love is a complicated messy thing
and let's use Marvel movies to do it
hell yeah let's let's uh let's tell new
stories that these audiences aren't used
to don't worry about the good looking
and the ABS that's one component of love
yeah hope I hear that we could make that
make it yeah
what happened to you Erik was a lot well
whatever is underneath the table hurt me
I'm not gonna be standing up for a long
time that's really creepy and gross
speaking of weird things in your body
what about the ether in that still in
Jane Foster and so essentially it's an
infinity stone can that because they
remember this so the concept is they had
to go back and put all the stones back
where they were
so they shoved it up Natalie Portman's
knows yeah and then she has it they
total recalled her back somehow maybe
while she was sleeping they put a funnel
in her mouth imagine a funnel if you
will a cone with a tube at the bottom
and we're familiar it's an angry sludge
we did a whole bit about this in a
recent Thor love and thunder breakdown
where it's just like imagine that
conversation between cap and Jane when
she's waking up like we just had we
please drink this I don't want to force
you to drink it but for the sake of the
multiverse you have to drink this right
now she's like oh great if I can be
cancer because that would Aaron's story
like yeah I don't it depends on what
timeline they they put this in if it is
the post endgame timeline yeah Jane
Foster has that has had that sludge in
her but through the result of the dark
world story has had it extracted from
her but has a memory of having an angry
toxic sludge inside of her it's a weird
dark world was a weird time guys are a
lot of depth yeah yeah do you guys I
think that that'll be how she gets the
powers if from the stone is it stores
just like here have it because he does
have an extra hammer a lot of shows like
to do this but it's like the whole
secret thing so I imagined that that we
might find out that she doesn't know
that that's what's inside her and that's
how are we saying that that's how the
cancer started it's a way okay I mean
I'll say if everything causes cancer
definitely an infinity stone in your
bloodstream probably does yeah and I
feel like it's gonna be this really
dramatic thing where it's like strange
her doctor yeah doctor changes the
oncologist
exactly so I think we'll have some sort
of reveal that will make her make a
decision about who she wants to be or
why well that's the hero's journey right
you have to choose at some point to
become the hero yeah Oh real quick I
just reminded myself just stupid theory
that I have and I want to put it on
record
Wanda vision Scarlet Witch is pregnant
with vision babies Oh babies twins and
then something happens to them and then
Paul she goes nuts can vision conceive I
just heard a rumor that vision shootin
blanks that's what he told you but chase
paprika he can't father a child I don't
know what that means but speaking of the
whole southern adage still being melt
down there lone wolf Top Gun do you guys
watch Top Gun maverick just remind us
what the character's name is so okay so
Tom Cruise surprises everyone by knowing
what comic-con is at all and then
showing up there and dropping a sequel
trailer for Top Gun which honestly is
kind of one of these movies that it's
like oh yeah Top Gun and then most
people saying that we're not born when
Top Gun familiar with Top Gun did you
guys watch Top Gun yeah yeah yeah you
guys are big top E's we both come from
families of pilots so we grew up with
Top Gun the same no pilot loved Top Gun
pilot we fill it in my background naval
aviation buddies they watch it this is
how you die right yeah but I kind of
adoringly in a way I don't know if
anyone views it as art its art yeah well
okay earlier by reading to me that you
think Tom Cruise is art
oh yes I do love him and I know you
think I'm being facetious
and then I sound sarcastic because I
suck a stick but I actually do
legitimately really love Tom Cruise like
when he smiles and put on and puts on
his aviator glasses and Top Gun I'm like
oh haha be still my heart I can't I just
I adore him and I think he's a really
great actor and I love that he does all
of his own stunts like are you kidding
he's the guy who's like I only want to
speed on a motorcycle not wear a helmet
I'm gonna try to fly this jet at like a
bunch of mocks like I'm gonna learn how
to do it it's a wuss
I hope it is like he's one of a kind
I'll say in front of the camera he's
he's amazing
you know what I mean like as the person
who gave us these moments a cinematic
history I hope he never dies it's up he
eventually very much will die doing one
of these stunts oh yeah yeah you got it
like he's kind of like a classic
old-school Hollywood show me in the way
Buster Keaton was wait Jackie Chan has
been in his career like I do my own
stunts I'm going to train myself how to
do it we're gonna rehearse it a ton of
times I might injure myself but like
there is kind of a death wish that we
all have and we go see these movies like
Tom Cruise potentially dying he's kind
of like the Evel Knievel of Hollywood
right now we gonna be an Evel Knievel
biopic and it was potentially gonna star
him at one point and then he's gonna do
all of his okay so about this good movie
it's hard to understand how it's gonna
land in our zeitgeist
but I think that it's potentially
setting itself up to be another Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull it's like like
you're taking this well semi beloved
franchise from from the 80s bringing it
back way later and not rebooting it
saying this old man is the only person
that can still play this role and you
also have miles teller in there who is
potentially gonna play that Shia LaBeouf
kind of role of hey I'm jr. or whatever
with monkeys yeah that swingin with
monkeys roll so yeah so how do we take
the lessons learn from kingdom of
Crystal Skull and not repeat those
mistakes on Top Gun maverick miles is
supposed to be like it's like goose
Junior right right so maybe he dies real
quick yeah bridge gets new that's
Deadpool look this is one of those
things where it's kind of a kingdom of
Crystal Skull where people like is this
movie necessary is any movie necessary
whatever it's you know it's the
directors great this is a guy who's been
doing all the Mission Impossible movies
Crispin Corey's great writer director he
did the usual suspects one could Tom
Cruise loves working with them and
brings him on to basically any project
he does now it'll be fun I love that the
trailer opened with like Ed Harris just
being like look in any other military
career you would not still be flying
jets this is really an intervention and
the only way you can have a serious
conversation with Tom Cruise is by
committing him to do a movie from it I
think the only way this movie's gonna
work is if what's been successful in the
past is if they introduce it and then
kind of let go of the old guard and then
kind of let it take its own thing
whereas with Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull it was very much like no we're
gonna keep it the same way that it's
been so there really was no handoff even
though they like fakes the whole hat
they put on the news like now give me my
hat it's kind of gotta be honest they
don't have to change the whole script
because he refused to give him the Hat
and I whether it's a bit or not I
believe it yeah I mean they're just
gonna have to hand over the jet maybe
have like they're gonna have to have
somebody else push the ladder up to the
wing so that he can climb it
like that's just what's gonna happen I
didn't know what you mean until you said
the ladder to get into the Jets
you mean the ladder the most recent
thing the ladder ladder point yeah I
just wonder why that person had to get
fired
just a little factor KY maybe blow you
away we're talking about kingdom of
crystals cause like you know this big
failure seventy eight percent on Rotten
Tomatoes do you know what top gonna have
some rotten tomatoes seventy eight
percent it's a movie people remember
maybe you don't want to rewatch it what
was it your the off-screen producers
saying they used the same Kenny Loggins
song three times yes having this great
contract contract with Tom Cruise and a
contract for a movie that uses the same
song but not that's not the volleyball
song that's a different end of the
trailer where they go to the Top Gun
theme on piano and it's like are you
kidding me we're five years too late on
that thing
Jurassic Park yeah confuses me now it
makes me think it's a horror movie or
something do you guys forget Jennifer
Connelly's in this cuz I mean she she's
gonna save it she's so hot beautiful and
so good yeah she's his love interest
last second turn that I did not expect
but Jennifer Connelly come groom us guys
rogue questions we end every episode
with some real hard-hitting questions
and if you get them wrong you're not
invited back these are opinion based
specifically get them all wrong good of
a time scarier trailer it Chapter two or
cats
cats cat yeah
yeah I mean I'd be it they're both funny
and scary isn't it in a way but man I'll
never get that image of the James Corden
or Billups card is upside down he's
insane he's not reading any shows a new
world set during World War two whoo yeah
oh that's really cool yeah would you
rather be in the Old West feudal Japan
or world war two Europe Old West because
you feel a little bit more okay being a
black Hatter or white hat wears in World
War two there's only one side you can
pick which enjoys Wow Western writing
specifically on quarter horses so I'll
go with the the western part what is a
quarter horse it's a specific breed of
horse fill up is it a twice the horse
that you put a quarter in I'm gonna say
feudal Japan why um because of the type
of weaponry they do have the best
webinar sure guns the actor cast as
shang-chi is in the upcoming Marvel
movie
he's so this is true if you guys thought
he had tweeted to Marvel eight months
ago about beam cast he's like hey you
guys want to cast me uh it's not like
Marvel let's talk or something and then
he got it they did cast so what role
should each of you start tweet begging
for obviously Eric in the Christmas
story they do have Peter Billingsley in
the MCU now and he's a producer for
Sandman let's see what's the name of
mojo I saw there was a female pilot in
the new Top Gun and I was like what yeah
I want to audition for that I would have
tweeted that and said make me that pilot
yeah that would been very very cool
Wesley Snipes congratulated me Hershel
alley on beat
but you know he didn't but you didn't
really mean it because he wanted to pay
taxes Malaysian him on being cast as
blade before telling angry fans to
chillax with a lot of a lot of exes
what's a more vampire appropriate way to
tell people to calm down
suck it up don't let that blood boil
it's and you say a vampire the trailer
for the zombie land sequel came out this
week and it shows the characters playing
twister in an abandoned White House
where would you want to explore in the
post-apocalyptic world ooh a theme park
like Disneyland Disneyland like or
they're not Disney but just abandon
theme parks and a room with weeds and
raccoons are out there operating the
rides now like one of those old like
refineries are like a distillery that
has like something that has huge tanks
and a lot of spaces you have to like run
through why and heard great things like
la the city of Los Angeles would be nice
just say yeah no traffic Bill Murray
Shaquille O'Neal was spotted dancing in
the front row of an EDM concert in
Belgium of cultures yeah what's the
worst person to be behind
[Laughter]
I'll get the giant yeah especially now
the person standing behind Shaquille
O'Neal because they're just fussing the
whole time I'd rather not be able to see
them be able to hear complaining for two
hours or the person recording the
concert with their iPad last one a wild
reddit theory came out this week that
when Captain America went back in time
at the end of endgame Steve Rogers
became mr. Rogers does make the upcoming
Tom Hanks movie a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
the secret forced Captain America solo
movie this is one of those questions
that's more of a joke for the card
writer
for a future video over here guys like
Tom Hanks yes more than Tom Cruise no
guys thank you so much to my guess you
guys are great and you can be found in
great places specifically where where do
you want people to find you yeah if I
man youtube.com under my name Tara
Ericsson its t-ara Eri ckin great you
can find me at the UCB theater on Harold
night with my teens scream in Los
Angeles in Los Angeles specifically uh
and you know where to find me you can
find me what do we got coming this week
oh yeah we got some interesting takes
we're still unpacking all the comic-con
stuff it should be on the channel
already this look at the horror
influences of Doctor Strange in the
multiverse madness to me the most
interesting panel about you guys was the
in-game screenwriters panel Markus and
McFeely gave us a sneak peek at all the
deleted scenes and ideas that were
rejected they had some of the craziest
ideas for both infinity war to cap cap
it was one we already did a video about
that there's another one about Thanos's
trial that you'll be able to see soon
and yeah just more stuff coming out of
Comic Con and we know that the end game
and getting released on DVD blu-ray will
be coming out in a couple weeks and
hopefully some more trailers for stuff
that we didn't get to see a comic-con
alright guys don't forget to subscribe
to rogue theory on the podcast feed so
you can get it earlier than the youtube
channel also I'm Philip Mele and I never
say my name at this time cuz it smelt
stupid you can also follow me on Twitter
and Instagram and Narok serves thank you
guys so much
[Music]